Ça ne concerne pas que des personnes âgées.
Ça concerne tout le monde.
Voici Richard.
Phase terminale, maladie du poumon.
« Richard, qu'est-ce qui est sacré pour vous ?
-- Mes enfants, ma femme et ma Harley. »
(Rires)
« Très bien !
On ne va pas faire une virée car je sais à peine faire du vélo,
mais voyons ce qu'on peut faire. »
Richard est venu me voir,
et il était en mauvaise forme.
Il avait cette petite voix lui disant
qu'il ne lui restait peut-être que quelques semaines ou mois.
Et nous avons juste parlé,
j'ai écouté et essayé d'entendre --
grosse différence.
Utiliser ses oreilles à la place de sa bouche.
J'ai dit : « Très bien, avançons jour après jour,
comme pour chaque autre chapitre de notre vie. »
Et nous avons rencontré Richard, qui avance jour après jour.
C'est un ou deux coups de téléphone par semaine,
mais il profite de sa vie malgré sa maladie en phase terminale.
La médecine palliative n'est pas seulement pour les personnes âgées,
elle n'est pas seulement pour les personnes d'âge moyen.
Elle est pour tout le monde.
Voici mon ami Jonathan.
Nous avons l'honneur et le plaisir
d'avoir Jonathan et son père ici aujourd'hui.
Jonathan a la vingtaine, je l'ai rencontré il y a quelques années,
Il combattait un cancer métastasé des testicules, qui s'est propagé
jusqu'au cerveau.
Il a eu un AVC,
puis une chirurgie du cerveau,
des rayons, de la chimiothérapie.
Quand je l'ai rencontré avec sa famille,
il était à deux semaines d'une greffe de moelle osseuse,
et en écoutant et en s'engageant,
ils ont dit : « Aidez-nous à comprendre -- qu'est-ce que le cancer ? »
Comment en sommes-nous arrivés là,
sans comprendre contre quoi nous nous battons ?
Comment en sommes-nous arrivés là, sans permettre aux gens
de savoir contre quoi ils se battent,
et ensuite pour qu'ils comprennent qui ils sont en tant qu'humains
pour savoir si c'est ce que nous devons faire ?
Dieu sait que nous pouvons vous faire toutes sortes de choses.
Mais devrions-nous ?
Et ne me croyez pas sur parole.
Toutes les preuves relatives aux soins palliatifs
démontrent tout à fait que les gens vivent mieux et plus longtemps.
Il y avait un article du New England Journal of Medicine
en 2010.
Une étude faite à Harvard par des amis, des collègues.
Phase terminale d'un cancer du poumon :
un groupe avec des soins palliatifs,
et un second groupe sans.
Ceux du groupe avec les soins palliatif ont constaté moins de douleurs,
moins de dépression.
Ils avaient besoin de moins d'hospitalisations.
Et, mesdames et messieurs,
ils ont vécu trois à six mois de plus.
Si les soins palliatifs étaient un médicament contre le cancer,
chaque docteur sur Terre le prescrirait.
Pourquoi ne pas le faire ?
Parce que nous, docteurs maladroits en blouse blanche,
sommes entraînés à traiter avec ça,
non pas avec ça.
C'est quelque chose que nous connaîtrons tous à un moment donné.
Mais cette conversation, aujourd'hui, n'est pas à propos de la mort.
C'est à propos de la vie.
Vivre avec nos valeurs,
ce que nous avons de sacré
et comment nous voulons écrire les chapitres de notre vie,
que ce soit le dernier
ou les cinq derniers.
Ce que nous savons,
ce que nous avons prouvé,
c'est que cette conversation doit avoir lieu aujourd'hui,
pas la semaine prochaine, pas l'année prochaine.
Ce sont nos vies qui sont en jeu aujourd'hui
et nos vies pendant que nous vieillissons
et les vies de nos enfants et de nos petits-enfants.
Pas seulement dans cette chambre d'hôpital
ou sur le canapé à la maison,
mais partout où nous allons et tout ce que nous voyons.
La médecine palliative est la réponse pour coopérer avec des humains,
pour changer ce voyage que nous allons tous envisager,
et le changer pour le meilleur.
A mes collègues,
à mes patients,
à mon gouvernement,
à tous les êtres humains,
je demande qu'on se lève, qu'on crie et qu'on demande
les meilleurs soins possibles,
pour qu'on puisse mieux vivre aujourd'hui
et assurer une meilleure vie demain.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons besoin de changer
pour pouvoir vivre demain.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)